Hello!
Meow Meow!
Is that better?
Hello!
Meow meow!
Meowty!
Hello!
Is the audio...
Okay.
Maybe?
I just realized I ate I hope you don't hear my stomach go I
hope you don't hear I had breakfast but I'm trying to get
rid of stuff that's in my fridge in my hotel and so I ate
fried rice for breakfast so then I'm gonna mute the cough
again I need a tissue eventually
My cough goes away.
I wonder if I should have something playing well in the
background.
So that's like when I cough and mute.
It's not just deafening silence to your coughing baby ASMR.
It's okay.
Meow if it's okay.
Meow if it's okay Good meow nink minto Good meow nink minto
Excited to chill with some minto ASMR And I hope you have
safe travels tomorrow Or whenever you leave Thank you Meow
Meow Meow Okay
Yes Yes Sorry if you can hear my little PC Just meow come on
I don't know if you noted it but Ace Combat account just
announced their application for North American content
creators just opened I will try mm-hmm super liminal thank
you so much for the 10 gifted and Majindee thank you for the
five gifted I will become ace combat combat combat combat
content i almost said combat creator instead of content
creator i must cough again i'm sorry
combat creator um i wish i had more to share with you guys
about my trip honestly it's been maybe the worst trip of my
afterlife I've been having fun but just like in terms of
getting sick and then all my plans falling through and then
being so busy with work and there's so much I wish I could
tell you guys about still That's all stuff that will happen
later.
It's okay though.
Worse than the Matara trip.
I think so because even though we had COVID together during
that trip, it wasn't nearly so long.
so um it was a shorter trip and i could go home earlier and
um get back to things but with this it's just like i might i
would wake up every i'm sorry i don't mean to to complain
but it was so funny because i would wake up every day and i
would have symptom so I think I just had a cold but then
then I would wake up I don't know I was telling I was
talking to then said to about it more the other day and they
were like no I think you had the flu and because I you know
started out with like me coughing a little sore throat and
then then I went to bed then I woke up I had the chills I
was like oh no I'm cold and I'm sweaty at the same time and
then then I had a fever
I was fine after a couple days enough to go outside and I
went outside where did I go?
I went to an idol show I went to an idol show and I was
totally fine besides like just coughing the entire time and
then afterwards I was like oh I think I like my adrenaline
got me through the show and I think my adrenaline got me
through the show and then afterwards I went to go have ramen
and I was sitting there, I ate two bites of my ramen and I
was like, what whoa, and I, oh my gosh, it was so
embarrassing.
I was like walking through the train station because that's
where I got it before I left.
I got two bites and then I was holding my mouth walking to
the, to the bathroom.
to not throw up.
Luckily, I made it to the bathroom and throw up.
It was so embarrassing.
I was so bad.
Yeah, I don't know.
It's just been rough.
It's been rough.
So I'm sorry I have no probably no fun stories to tell at
the moment.
But in due time, I will be able to talk about some things.
feeling sick is rough when if you aren't at home Tokyo and I
were talking about that literally yesterday because our
trips happen to align and I only got to see her yesterday we
went and we got afternoon tea together which is my second
afternoon tea of this trip I think I'm obsessed with
afternoon tea because I
I don't eat a lot at once you know I like eat a little and
then in like a couple hours I'm hungry yeah Vicky's rubbing
off on me for real okay yeah but if you don't know what
afternoon tea is it's basically you get your tea it's less
focused on the tea it's more about the desserts hold on I
have to cough again
But yeah, it's like, um, you get like little sandwiches and
you get, it's like a sampler platter.
It's so great.
And the one I went to yesterday was so cute, but we couldn't
finish it all.
And I also got to hang out with Emu-Di a little bit too.
I love her.
And I got to see Pia once this trip Who else did I get to
see?
I guess not so many people I was sick
Pia, Pia, Pia, P Slime, slime girl The boars!
I didn't get to actually see the boars.
I... Oh wait, was there a donald?
I'm so sorry.
I don't have my headphones in.
Wait.
Should I turn those on?
Was it loud?
Wait, could you hear it?
Can't hear it.
Okay, good.
But thank you.
Thank you.
I went hiking and the people that were worked there they
were like watch out these are boar these are boar footprints
and I was like I have I know the boars in Japan are
dangerous but I want to see and then also the area that I
went hiking I say hiking more walking but uh afterwards they
were like this mountain in the daytime beautiful this
mountain at night full of ghosts and I was like I I want to
I want to I need to go be there what was it like seeing
Steiner in Japan
It was really funny because we, as Densetsu, all went hiking
together and we went quite far out.
It was about, it was a couple hours on train that we were,
we were, we were out for.
And so on the way back, we were quite tired and we were
slow.
sleepy.
And, um, um,
I, uh, there were not enough seats on the train for me to
sit with everybody, so I sat across.
So it was Vicky, Vicky, Steiner in the middle, and Phoebe.
And I was just watch.
I was just observing.
And Vicky was literally like this on the train.
head back eyes closed relaxed trying to get some rest and I
kid you not every two minutes at least Steiner would look
over to her and just be like this girl's trying to sleep and
then And as soon as he was done sucking the life, the energy
from Vicky, he turned to Phoebe.
And I looked over at him for, I looked over at him at one
point and I was like, will you shut up and let her sleep?
Can you stop talking for five minutes?
And then after I kind of brought that up to him, after the
train we were just walking because we were headed to dinner
together we were all gonna get yaki niku and he's just like
reading signs he's like mmm hair salon mmm pachinko oh I
heard that one 137 miles on the Appalachian Trail oh my gosh
a memory memories with my monkey good job
you guys heard it a little
but he would just start reading things and then he looked at
me and he was like oh no oh no mint I think I get it I
understand what you're talking about now I just I just talk
I just I just can't stop talking I'm having a realization
Because I would notice it Throughout the trip I was like Man
this guy really talks This guy is a yapper for real And I
You know I'm an intro I'm a ghost.
I'm not used to people seeing me.
So degree in yappanomics.
Yeah, this guy is a yapper.
And he also is so big-headed.
The most big-headed person I've ever met.
He's like, he'll be like, man, great being me and then at
one point he points at me at dinner and he says he says she
causes me to drink she drives me to drink and I think you
know I was like I think this guy really hates me.
And
everything that I say about him is self-defense.
Because if it wasn't Steiner, I would think you were
slandering him.
No, it's self-defense, I swear.
This guy hates me.
It's proof he sees you as a friend.
Yeah, I guess this too is British culture, huh?
I guess this too is British culture.
Can you hear my drink?
I'm drinking Aquarius.
Do you guys prefer Bokari sweat or Aquarius?
Bokari, Bokari, Bokari.
Woe.
Only ever had Bokari.
Given that he likes to drink it's a compliment.
The only other thing that happened to was hiking.
I had an umbrella.
As a ghost.
I don't do well in the sun.
Calvus.
The kelpus is not a sports drink.
But, um, I was in the sun for a bit.
I usually have a parasol, but I couldn't use it the whole
time.
And now, my ectoplasm has like, I get, I have like an
allergy or something.
I don't know what, that's the only equivalent I can think of
for humans.
Now, I have like, I have, I have bumps all over where I, I,
uh, got those saws in.
I can't go outside.
I'm too weak.
Now, it's been such a, it's been a trip for me.
It's been one thing after another.
I'm ready to go home.
Yeah.
Yeah, maybe I'm more vampire than ghost.
A carrier con will be first, but yeah, carrier con will be
this weekend.
But I'm worried about the concert.
I hope I don't cough too much on it.
Steiner the energy vampire is budding heads with a classic
vampire.
No, my rice this morning had garlic in it.
I can't be a vampire.
I'm a garlic girl.
I think I can.
I got the worst sunburn, windburn bumps during a hollow
fish.
Isn't that inside?
A Wraith?
Maybe, yeah.
Yeah.
Wine gone.
I didn't get to go to Hollow Fest.
I was asked if I wanted to go.
But it's a good thing I had no plans because I was too sick.
I wouldn't have been able to go So yeah, what else did I do?
I've seen some idols Let me go through my phone and see
pictures That I've taken
There's so few pictures Hold on,
how?
have pictures of afternoon tea.
I got to take Vicky and Phoebe to my favorite tea place,
which is called Q-pot.
And,
um, it's, they make really cute things like necklaces.
They make cute, um, how do you say?
but it's like a lot of it is like biscuits and macarons
things like that so it's very Q like the letter Q and pot
like a pot on the stove
Q pot shopping stream 2.0 if you ever need to get like a
It's quite expensive, but if you ever need to get a nice
present for somebody, if you're trying to impress a girl, my
two recommendations are one, Q-pot, and two, Gelato Peek.
If anyone buys jewelry and food accidentally bites into the
jewelry, but maybe, might be me sooner than you think.
Gelato Peake Gelato Peake P-I-P-P-I-Q-U-E P-I-Q-U-E is a
it's a pajama brand not gelato bacon I didn't say bacon.
I said bacon.
But in Japan they say bacon.
But it's pajamas.
And they do...
They do...
Lots of collabs with fun brands and stuff.
Like right now, last I saw was...
was...
Sesame Street.
But they do Pokemon.
How did you hear bacon?
How?
Good.
How to do your bacon.
Bacon, bacon, bacon, bacon, bacon, bacon, bacon, bacon,
bacon, bacon, bacon, bacon, bacon, bacon, pancakes.
Because we're hungry.
Using your final record beer coasters.
I'm so good.
Piket sounds like a bacon.
It's like a blue dress, white dress.
Oh, wait!
Do you guys... Okay, I'm gonna say something.
Tell me what you hear.
Yanni, Yanni, Yanni,
Yanni, Yanni.
Laurel.
You guys are so good at that.
You guys are so...
Oh, tell me, tell me what you hear.
Tell me what you hear.
Meow, meow, meow, meow, meow.
Yesterday, after karaoke, all day I walked around.
And I said, I
couldn't stop.
I can't stop.
I don't want to forever meow.
I want to forever meow.
I want to be forever meow.
Do you really want to meow forever and ever?
Well, I was meowing all day.
Sorry, hold on, I gotta,
I gotta cough.
Can you say, I I want chicken, I want liver.
Meow mix, meow mix, please, your liver.
One time when I was a kid, we had a family dog, right?
And our dog really liked a certain brand of dog treats.
So I made a song about it.
And my mom was like, and tell them your song and so we
called the company and I was like hello I would like to sing
a song about oh sorry if you heard that hi dog meow meow I
called the company I said I would like to sing a song and
they said okay and it was like I don't remember the name of
the doctorates anymore but I can remember I
can remember some of it
because it would be like I was like explaining the lyrics at
the same time I remember it was like i'm just gonna call
them dog treats i was like dog treats dog treats they love
them so dog treats dog treats it makes them blow and then i
was like it's they're blowing because they're farting
because it made my dog fart a lot
i'm sorry to the customer service agent that had to listen
to me and then i was like they're running and jumping they
can't get enough of the dog treats dog treats they love them
so and i was like and after i was done
the lady was like that was very lovely i will send you some
coupons and so we got coupons for the dog treats and my mom
would make me do this like quite often be like if you call
the companies and not just complain but also compliment the
stuff you'll get coupons because they like good feedback too
but she would use me because she thought we would get more
coupons I
was used for coupons
child labor indeed Yeah, my mom was a hustler.
She was like, Minto, Minto, I know you're a ghost, but
ghosts got a hustle too.
I didn't get sent to normal uh, summer camps.
I got sent to uh, entrepreneur summer camps.
That would be like...
You'll...
You'll have to...
You'll have to work in this world.
Business class for babies.
Oh yeah.
My mom really wanted me to be business savvy.
I guess I kinda own my own business.
An entrepreneur came up daughter about branding.
Maybe.
Thank you guys for all the super chats.
Thank you.
I'm a person of light.
Dabbling in the ways of us.
I am from a young age.
Oh, yeah.
I would have a lemonade stand, and the road, I would be able
to, what I would do is, I would line the road with pine
cones, right?
Like, or anything rocks, anything that would show up as a
line in the middle of the road.
drove.
They would stop because they're like, what's this in the
middle of the road?
And I would be like, oh, hello.
While you're here, please enjoy.
Would you like a cup of my lemonade?
Rosemindo, I think you dropped this.
No, no.
Thank you.
Yeah, it worked.
It worked quite well.
Yeah, they were, I would, they were roadblocks that you
could get around, it was just like, you know, they would see
something in the middle of the road and they would be like,
what is that?
I must stop.
Didn't join her friend's MLM because she has the road.
At least it didn't cut down trees to block the road.
Not yet.
Pay the acorn toll to pass one lemonade.
Yeah, that's what I would do.
To sell my lemonade.
Was trick the people into stopping.
That'll be in front of the dead sister closer.
Ghost can't go to jail.
I could go to ghost jail.
but I'm scared there's some hardcore ghosts in there I don't
know if you ever watched Ed and Eddie but I feel like you
and Eddie would be besties don't say that
yeah I might get ghost busted I can't wink and my glasses
wait let me try again
when live makes makes love wait when life when life gives
you lemons don't make lemonade make life take the lemons
back yes yes i don't think i was so much of a menace though
i don't think so i don't think i was so much of a menace
because i
was also i was on the safety patrol
I ruled the hallways of the school with an iron fist.
An iron paw.
Yeah, but I went mad with power.
Yeah, I was a hall monitor.
Except I was one above the hall monitor.
I got... I got the...
How do you say?
A promotion.
It's way too hot here.
I forgot the ice cream I bought in the car trunk.
Oh no!
Honestly, it was hard packing for my trip because I was
like, I don't know how hot it will be.
I don't know how cold it will be.
I knew it would be cold but I didn't know how much warmer it
would be.
And so many of my outfits I haven't been able to wear
because it's been so cold in Japan.
The ruthless business ghost could sell lemons to life.
I'm putting on some lip balm.
Life-size Gundam I have seen before.
The one in Otayba I've seen.
I'm sorry, I have to keep stopping to cough.
I'm sorry.
What's some more ASMR I can do?
Peepo, peepo, peepo, peepo, peepo.
Head scratches, I can try.
Tell me how this feels.
Loud.
I have a, how do you say?
screen cover for my mic but when I put it on people usually
say that my mic sounds muffled so I take it off so I'm just
been I'm yeah it's like a pop filter yeah yeah the thumbnail
made for a rather relaxing invitation a crystal clear night
sky full of stars accompanied by a flower Indeed.
Now, raw dog in the audio.
Well, usually at home I don't have one either.
I don't have a pop filter.
So, heartbeat?
I don't have one.
I could like, I don't know, make my ectoplasm simulate it.
Can I?
Get a drink.
You guys, I found the best almond milk ever in Japan.
I'm going to put you down.
I saw it when I first saw it.
I was like, this looks so good.
Just from the vibes.
I was like, these vibes look on.
Mmm.
I have a hash.
I'm going to miss this drink.
Which is
the thing that I've never liked about almond milk is how
thick it is, right?
Usually when you drink it, it feels so thick.
And,
yeah, I usually drink oat milk.
But this one, it just tastes...
Oh, yeah.
I can't grab it a certain way or else it spills on the
ground.
I have my own chicken now.
We all have our own chickens.
I now have my own chicken.
They're multiplying, yes.
What's its name?
Shall we name it together?
Let's name it.
Hmm.
Chicken tendy.
Then we...
Solidus!
Wait!
Solidus is so good.
Because that's what the chickens were like named.
Liquid and Solidus.
And MGS4.
Solidus.
Here, I'll squeeze him from afar.
I'll squeeze him from afar.
So it is Tendy
Now Born on a Monday It's Thursday
Can you guys hear my computer?
I will put it Close the mic.
Oh, you can.
Nice.
This little guy does his best.
And he does a good job, I think.
He does his best, and he does a great job.
What time has ever been?
It just hit 10 a.m., baby.
Hold on, I'm gonna cough.
8 p.m., 1 a.m., You should go to sleep.
If it's 1am, you should go to sleep.
Go to sleep, go to sleep.
Go to sleep, little baby.
Koduka got time for you.
I don't think I'll do an afternoon nap today.
I have some things that I want to do today, I think so.
My plans for the rest of the day, might meet up with Doki
again.
Maybe.
But maybe not.
I think I'll have to message her.
And but I think we talked about yesterday maybe getting
lunch together.
And then I have tickets to an event in the evening.
If you do tell her we say, I will heal.
We were talking last night we were like oh we miss streaming
uh i want to go back home and get back to regular
yeah have fun thank you thank you thank you they miss us i
still always feel quite bad when my plans go awry intend on
streaming more but it doesn't happen but I could I'm glad I
could at least get a couple times I had 10 set to off collab
I had blue archive I had fatal frame I had yesterday I had
oh today so I guess and then I had portal so a couple thank
you Oh,
I love me too, yeah, yeah, I love me also.
Will you continue Fatal Frame?
I'd like to!
I really would!
I'll have to continue Fatal Frame?
Well, we gotta finish Bioshock.
You always keep us well fed me too.
I don't know.
No, no, no.
No, no.
Oh, no.
Thank you.
And I have to finish Bioshock.
I saw someone ask earlier about the Barry, Barry, Barry,
Barry game.
I do want to finish that too.
I had games all lined up.
I always line up streaming games.
Things that I think like a smaller PC like mine would be
able to handle.
I just feel so bad I wasn't able to do any of them resting
glitch please thank you so much for the vibe I think it's
mostly like my cough has only just started getting better
the past couple of days so there was it's my cough is mostly
activated by when I run around and there was sometimes when
Tensetsu we were doing dance practice and stuff and I was
literally on the floor I was on the floor like coughing it
was so bad
yeah so I felt like it would be hard for extreme yeah I was
doing sick moves on the ground yeah
dying Victorian child there was one day that it snowed in
Tokyo and I was laying in bed watching the snow fall from
the sky and I was like I'm a dying Victorian child and this
is my last view
I wonder why I wonder what Or I wonder what my last video
was before I died.
Maybe it was the snow.
Yeah, I'm Blade Runner guy.
Isn't that like a meme?
Like a men want to die in like the snow.
The turtle snow.
That's like...
Yeah, I'm bleeding out in the snow, yeah.
there was another movie I saw I watched it on the plane it
was about I can't remember the name excited for more fatal
frame thank you thank you thank you
10 out of 10 would bleed out it was a It was a movie about a
guy who...
Who...
It was like the Civil War in America.
And...
He's trying to get back to this lady that he loves.
In the end, I think he dies.
I think he bleeds out in the snow.
Falling in the snow, bleeding out.
Makes Red Snow Angels epic.
cold mountain yes I think that's what it was I think that's
what it was cold mountain and he finally gets to her and
then gets shot and bleeds out in the snow and I watched that
movie I watched it on the plane and there's a scene where
the guy gets like he's staying at some people's house and
the daughters of this one guy are like stripping and taking
off their shirts and they're like oh yeah come on mister
don't you want to go to bed with me and I was like why is
this on the plane now everybody around me is is knowing that
I am watching bare naked ladies on the plane
But I never knew that was a trope.
You know?
That men want one thing, it's to bleed out in the snow.
Being sad.
Well, what?
In the snow always makes me think of the canon.
Oh yeah.
Do, do, do.
Do.
Do... do... oh, only after defeating our enemies.
I think it's a very romantic way to go out.
We romanticize almost everything except romance itself.
I think maybe men love tragic romance too.
Maybe.
She ain't beaten the allegations.
What allegations?
Can we bleed out in the snow outside my cafe?
No, it's messy.
You only think about the bleeding out part.
What am I supposed to do with your body after?
I'd never want something like that.
You promise you'd krill us yourself.
Just like sniper wolf.
Eat it!
Oh my gosh.
My cafe is gonna turn into Sweeney Todd.
The demon made of virtual Akihabara.
Give us to the hogs.
Cannibalism cafe.
It's so unbrand.
Revised.
Falls in snow, bleeds out, makes red snow angels while
singing meet the flintstones where were the flintstones come
in hmm hmm time to reset the counter cannibal but I didn't
mention the cannibalism you guys mentioned it it doesn't
count if you guys mention it first hold on I have to cough
throw me in the dumpster behind Burger King no though I did
I don't eat Burger King usually.
But Japanese Burger King, right now they have something
called like the Yeti Burger.
It's the Yeti Burger.
And it sounds awesome.
I kind of want to try it.
Burger King, Burger King Japan.
Wait, hold on, I'm going to look it up.
Oh wait, I guess this is a...
a re it's it's come back up before oh whoa this is not a new
thing it's old sounds more appetizing than the Bigfoot
burger number number 13 Bigfoot burger the last thing you'd
want in your Burger King burger is a Bigfoot but if you go
to Japan that just might be what you care a little lonely
without Chibendoki screaming I'm sorry Dixie I'm glad you
liked portal 2 though I haven't been reading the comments on
portal 2 because sometimes people are mean there was one
comment that was like oh yeah her head is just for
but it's okay
but as long as people liked it
it's okay ban that good 99% of the comments I saw were
positive that's good I just I chose for Portal not to read
them because I they don't remember how long they struggled
when they played I think that's you know a lot of people
kind of you know don't realize that they also struggle in in
game sometimes so when they see someone else struggle but
it's something that they that they know about it just it
seems so natural to them you know what I mean
So, I finished the game at 90 minutes.
I never played it.
Hell yeah.
So, yeah, they already know the answer.
But I chose just for my own mental to not look.
But if you left a really nice comment, I really appreciate
it too.
We even did the math and he were better than the average
player.
No way.
I took some time, though.
I took a little couple breaks, though, sometimes.
But I had so much fun.
I really don't mind if people...
Um...
If people...
I say things.
And honestly, it made me want to do more Let's Play style
stuff.
I was like, I wonder if I could, you know, on days that I
have off, have like a let's play thing, a let's play video
or something.
I would really enjoy it, I think.
I really would like to do more stuff like that.
You found unique solutions to the test.
I had so much fun with it.
for trips I'll do more um but yeah not knowing what's are
the ones who don't actually play games and watch
walkthroughs no no no it's okay I I like I said I understand
that especially you know when I recognize that I took a long
time on some puzzles and everything and you know I know that
there will always be loud people that say negative things.
It's okay.
I knew that.
I knew that going into playing it.
But I just saw, I did see some comments of people saying
things like, I wish more VTubers did let's play content like
this.
And how for like Portal 2, they were glad I played it
because some things maybe people would have spoiled.
Or the backseating would have been annoying or something.
So, the sped-up part had me howling.
So, I don't know.
I, at the same time, enjoy us experiencing it together.
But, yeah,
I only put together a year ago that making combustible
lemon.
was making lemonade lemonade instead of yeah i did i did see
someone i did see someone explain that one too lemon nades
that's so funny i don't think i ever got over that pun it's
too good it's too good portal 3 win i want portal 3 have
life 3 please return to making games please try I expect you
to die VR escape room game James Bond flavor enough but VR
at least with portal ill outlet would be so fun to have a
third one there's less of a story than there is with
half-life you know what I mean mm-hmm
Yeah, but I think it would be really fun to have Portal and
Half-Life meet.
Aperture desk job, is that a thing?
Hmm.
Yeah.
They are in the same world.
Exactly, exactly.
Technically, Portal 2 co-op is the third story.
I love that you could see the portal.
portal you could see the co-op guy in one of the puzzles it
was so fun i loved that i love that so much that was fun
peabody and atlas oh yeah definitely vicky and i have been
talking about playing the co-op together so that should be
sooner rather than later later.
Yes, hold on, I have to cough.
Oh.
Free the cough.
Now.
Yeah.
So, I don't know, I've been trying to think of a schedule
that I could do for Let's Play stuff.
Because, well, it would be nice to do it for only too.
I think a consistent let's play schedule would be nice as
well.
So,
can't recall if you've had a one-on-one collab with Vicky
yet.
I don't think so.
Inscription to the game I wanted to see.
I played for the story and secrets, but I know the back
seating would be crazy.
I'm just not very good with card games.
That's my thing.
Hmm.
Yeah, it's okay, you can cough on us, I volunteer, though.
Yeah, Control and Alan Wake, too.
I have another...
Streams are gonna still be a little after Carrier Con.
I do have an actual planned vacation for about a week in the
beginning of April.
um but i will have a let's play for that as well not sure
what to do yet but i'll have an idea
um but i apologize that it would be a little bit more yeah
it's a real vacation no work at all no work at all nothing i
just feel so bad because when i'm not streaming even if it's
because i'm doing work you know you guys don't see that
right so to me it feels like you guys might think like oh
she's just not streaming so hmm but there's cool things
coming like the like the 3d live we've been working really
hard for that yeah yeah yeah um with a lot of really cool
stuff for it um and some other things that i can't mention
too so yeah what sucks is i plan well there were two things
that i planned one thing like rather i could have come a bit
later to japan on this trip but there was the neatest dream
premiere that happened that I wanted to go see and then
there was one other thing that was being planned but
unfortunately it fell through but also fortunately it fell
through because I would have been sick so I felt like my
beginning of my trip was a total waste just an absolute
waste I could have been home that's a it off.
Sorry, you missed the premiere.
It's okay.
I'm excited, too.
Maybe...
Wait.
What might be even better is what if when it comes out, we
do a watch-along together?
I think I'm only in, like...
I'm only one of the first three episodes.
I think.
But if If we did a watch along, then I could point out where
I am.
Yeah, we'll do that then.
And I can be like, me!
That's me!
No time coughing.
Yeah, it'll be the DiCaprio meme.
It'll be the DiCaprio meme, but...
Me.
I can be like, I said that, and die, I said that.
Oh, needy eyeball overload.
Oh, I know that lady.
It would be so, it would be really surreal seeing my name in
the comments.
Minto in an anime is so cool.
It was such a crazy experience.
Yeah.
And very scary where I was being, yeah, I was being watched
and I was like, I've never done anything like this before.
I was brave.
Yeah, I didn't get to say too, but they also, they gave me a
tour of the YoStar animations too.
studios, which was really nice, because YoStar animated it.
So I got to go there too.
Yeah, I got to meet people on the team of the anime.
And at the YoStar animation studio, they have like figures
of things of like, they have like a bunch of Azure Lane
things, archive stuff they have water bottles that have uh
what's what uh arc knights did they the yostar anime the arc
knights anime i feel like they did did they yes right okay
so they have water bottles with arc knights on it they have
water bottles with blue archive on it um so i have a i have
a blue archive water bottle that I got to keep and I got to
see where all the animation gets done um it was really oh my
gosh I've never seen anything like it before so I was like
this is so cool koharu water bottle no koharu's not in the
anime yet
so Was that there where the Idol Master...
Oh no!
Da!
Nyaruda and I went around Nakano Broadway.
And in Nakano Broadway is the Idol Master Machine.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So, mm-hmm.
You got to play that.
Yeah.
Yeah, so it was just really nice.
It was a very freaky experience because, you know, I got to
meet like the cast of Needy Streamer and they're all
prolific, say you.
And they were like bringing up my Twitter and my YouTube
channel.
I was so embarrassed.
Yeah.
But it was really nice.
But they even offered to show me around and stuff.
I just, I'm just, I'm just a ghost.
I'm not even just a ghost.
I'm a ghost and I'm a maid.
I'm so low on the hierarchy.
It was, it was fun and scary.
I didn't know if I was doing anything correctly Especially
because, you know, my Japanese is Speaking is difficult for
me Listening is half okay But I'm more conversational, you
know If it's like technical terms they're trying to tell me
I'm like
So I was like, my Japanese was pushed to crazy level.
I was so, you know, just scary.
Ah, I don't care that, yeah, that was me.
receiving instructions in japanese i'm like huh
that's the best way to learn honestly did you get to meet
the yosef yostar who's that who is that sounds like it
sounds like jojo I don't know.
I don't know.
Joseph Jostar.
But yeah, it was fun.
But that was a while ago.
And And, uh,
I guess I really haven't done much of this trip, especially
things that I can't talk about right now.
Yo-Yo's Bizarre Animations Studio.
I learned something yesterday, though.
I learned about an Edoge that completely fell through my
radar.
Apparently, it's like the number one...
erogate downloaded on dl site
and they made an anime out of it and the anime is currently
having a collab at shibuya 109 and it's like about oh gosh
wait dl site it's okay hold on it's called what was it
nukitashi
Yeah, Nukitashi, the animation.
Apparently, there is a safe-to-play version on Steam.
And no way it has a Ponte Poole reference in it.
I was informed of, like, the plot, and I have to play it.
But I was informed that there's a safe-to-play version.
on steam and it's only two hours long but yeah I want to
play it so bad what's the plot it's like okay hold on I'm
just gonna look it up because I don't want to get any of the
details wrong okay it's like a sex island but it's like so
absurdly filled with age scenes that it's like it becomes
it's just like oh man they're having sex again like
let's see wait no no go to Wikipedia
the shirt that they had too at the pop-up was so funny uh
Plot On Seiran Island Perverted Echi Is mandatory and
encouraged Everywhere under the pervert law Junosuke and his
sister Return to the island from Tokyo After the death of
their parents Junosuke is disgusted by the law And refuses
to participate as he does not believe in etch without love.
He gathers so, and yeah, and then it becomes like there's
like a coalition, and then there's like a war between the
people that want to do etchy and don't want to.
He does not believe, oh, he gathers some like-minded people
into a group called no love, no etchy, but it's actually the
word that starts with es.
in front to protest the law but must dodge the advances of
several girls who are attracted to him
it's like actually it's like just kind of ridiculous it's
not supposed to be like you know like a sexy it's game it's
like more satirical and silly than anything i
want to play it yeah it's comical Yeah, ridiculous in a good
way.
Yeah, yeah.
It's so funny.
Um, I think I'll play the game and then I'll watch the anime
most likely.
What a hero.
Yeah.
He's Luca from Monster Girl Quest.
Nah!
It's true, though.
Oh, no.
There's too many women trying to get on me.
It's too buttery, my steak is too juicy.
I respect it, though.
And eat skin with love.
Poor guy.
But I don't like butter.
Get your friend at the outside to get you the uncensored
version.
Actually, I should, right?
I should, I should.
The opening.
I watch the opening to the anime.
And he's just holding
Etsy toys a lot.
And then there's guns.
I strongly recommend Uncensored for Run.
Okay, we'll do.
I will play.
I haven't been able to play visual novels in so long so I'm
just like really itching for it recently I've been really
itching for like a good visual novel it okay or not you know
what I mean hmm maybe I could start doing that as like a
member stream or something but it wouldn't be it okay
probably unless I could censor it I wheeled the toys like
nunchucks yeah yeah yeah
Yeah, yeah.
Have you considered Somnium Files?
I have!
I do want to play Somnium Files.
I wonder if I could do that for when I'm gone next.
Minky after Dark Stream.
but I'm not the after dark it's just just the content Steam
has a lot of safe versions of it okay yeah yeah yeah they do
read anything type moon I never got into like the type moon
universe I have fake memories of watching the Tsukihime
anime which I know a lot of people would be like, good, no,
good, no.
Oh my gosh, you guys could hear that?
That's crazy.
Does not exist.
Yeah, right, right, right.
Right, right, right.
But I don't know really anything about fate.
Hmm.
or anything
I too have false memories of saying this
but yeah I would like to get into it it'd be really neat
coming in as in 2026 someone that knows nothing about type
moon and learning all about it I think would be fun A lot of
Fate's face, but burned out on FGO.
Yeah.
Play Klanad.
I don't want to play Klanad again, I think.
Klanad was so long, and it also just breaks my heart.
It's so...
Steinsgate reboot.
I want to.
Yes.
I can't remember the last key.
I did Planetarian, I did Klanad, I did Kanon, I did Air.
I owned Little Busters, but it was before there was an
English patch for it, so I only had like the physical
version.
So I never actually got to play it.
And it was before the anime, the Little Busters anime came
out too.
I think that's where I've stopped with Ki for their visual
novels.
I haven't played anything since then.
I don't, maybe if you count Heaven Burns Red.
But I only downloaded the Mopake.
Yeah, I didn't try re-write.
Summer Pockets.
Oh, I've heard a good thing about Summer Pockets too.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hmm.
Now, I want to try.
But guys, unfortunately, I'm starting to get a little bit of
a headache.
I think I might nap.
I might nap until I need to go out.
So, and eat breakfast i want to eat breakfast too yeah yeah
yeah thank you guys for for uh hanging out with me for a bit
mm-hmm hopefully you were very relaxed with this chill ASMR
chit-chat and i'll be back in my regular streaming setup in
just a couple days now so I'll be back back to normal
streaming real soon But probably still coughing
Unfortunately, it takes me a while to get over it, I think
Give us some head scratches before I go.
Okay, one more
What's a minto?
Thank you guys.
Thank you.
Thank you I'll see you guys in a couple days Actually, wait,
if I see you at CarrierCon, I'll see you then If not, I'll
do probably a Like a Twitter space During CarrierCon Time to
feed my cats too Otu Otu, Otu, Otu Targo, thank you for the
big Hope the cough goes bye-bye fast Thank you Thank you,
thank you
I really appreciate the stress relief of the ASMR.
Of course.
Have a good day.
Have a good night.
On to me too.
Bye.
Bye bye.
Bye bye bye.
Bye bye bye bye.